[Music]
South Africa is welcoming some good news
with its water crisis we've told you how
cape town's water supply was set to run
out as early as this month because of a
crippling drought but thanks to extreme
conservation the so called day zero of
no water has been pushed back to 2019
global water shortages are still a
concern a recent UN report predicts more
than five billion people about
two-thirds of the world's population
could suffer water scarcity by 2050
Jamie yuccas visited one company in
Arizona with a possible solution that
makes drinkable water out of air most
people get their water from thousands of
miles away exactly you get it from right
there yeah it's cool the house exactly
for the past year Phoenix homeowner NIC
Robbins has been getting all of his
drinking water from an unlikely source
these panels on his roof it comes out of
his refrigerator spigot just like tap
water but it starts up here with these
they look like typical solar panels but
they're called source hydro panels and
they actually create water out of air so
you have 20 solar panels up on the roof
yep Cody freezin is the founder and CEO
of zero mass water an Arizona startup
that built the source system underneath
here are a set of materials that are
absorbing water from the atmosphere
sunlight goes into this part and that's
actually driving that process of taking
the water vapor back out of those
materials it condenses out naturally and
so then it goes into that line yep and
then down and then we can drink it
this is air made into water you got it
the biggest problem facing humanity is
drinking water if we can solve that
problem we fundamentally changed the
world so this is the map of where you're
at exactly at about $4,000 for a to
panel set freezin has already sold more
than a thousand systems in 10 countries
each one can produce about 20 16-ounce
bottles of water per day
you guys are based in Scottsdale Arizona
yep the desert if you can make water
from the air in Arizona passively you
can do it anywhere they've already
helped out in some of the world's
current water crises from hurricane
ravaged Puerto Rico to a girl's
orphanage for Syrian war refugees in
Lebanon these are young ladies who have
lost their families their homes their
country and otherwise would be consuming
water that would make them sick and we
were able to make it so that they have
perfect water at least that peace their
life was better the question is is it
scalable to a larger community or even
an entire city retired NASA
climatologist bill patzert sees promise
in the technology but he has some
reservations of course the next step
will be to see how economical it is on a
large scale so that we can use it not
only for a single home but for entire
communities is this really the solution
you're not getting a ton of water out of
these panels so each panel I agree makes
an amount of water for a biscuit family
of four but you can aggregate those
panels together to create big supplies
of water where that's necessary for
example in one acre we can do about five
thousand liters a day so pretty big
supplies like if Cape Town called and
said we want every single person in Cape
Town to have this installed at their
house would you be able to even do that
at this point the rate limiting step
would be the docks in Cape Town not us
period for now freeze ins hope is people
will use his source water as a
substitute for the four hundred billion
litres of bottled water sold each year
around the world when you're drinking
from source so you know exactly where it
came from
you know exactly that it's perfect you
know that it's right there it came from
this panel right here after that he
seems confident the sky's the limit for
CBS this morning
Jamie yuccas Scottsdale Arizona thanks
Jamie amazing anyone who's read dune
recognizes that technology from Arrakis